Today I'm going to show you how to tie your belt.
I'm going to show you the easiest way to do it.
It's not necessarily the "traditional" way,
but it's a way that works well and makes sure that it's all well set.
The first thing you do is to take it like this and fold it in half.
Make sur that the label is on the inside as you fold, not on the outside,
because at the end, you want the label to be out.
So here it is, fold it in half,
and then you're going to close your vest,
like this,
nice and tight.
Then you're going to place the center of the belt under your belly button.
Then you're going to wrap it around.
Like this.
Now from that point, what you want to do,
you're going to see that behind me, there is a cross here.
What you want to do is to straighten it because when you take ukemi, it can be a bit painful.
So put the thumb from your right hand
and slide the knot so that it goes to the front.
Then when it's at the front, it's going to being this side of the belt under the rest.
Then you're going to take the bit which is at the top,
and you're going to roll it under.
You roll it under and you take it back up.
From that point, you can center your belt a little bit.
Then you're going to take the bottom part and place it like this in the front.
Right in the front, like this,
and you're going to make the top part go under,
and back like this.
Then you end up with the belt like this.
This way, when you wear the hakama, you can hide it under.
You can also wear it down like this,
but it makes kind of a mess here so it's not as clean, so I prefer like this.
Then as you saw it at the beginning, the label here is showing upwards,
as opposed to being like this.
That comes from the fact that you folded your belt with the label inside.